hello everyone and welcome to a game i'm
pretty sure you guys knew i would cover
i started receiving notifications on my
phone about it before it even finished
you guys really uh started spamming that
hashtag suggestion across all of my
social media and uh then i decided to
check it out and then i saw of course
what was happening and it's funny
because i uh i was planning on showing
an arjun game today as uh yesterday he
broke into the world top 18 he overtook
shisht of duda as the world number 18 in
classical chess which is absolutely
spectacular
and uh he did it with a with a miniature
uh i think it was an 18 18 move
miniature uh
against uh against the grand master so
that was truly incredible uh but then i
you know logged in today and i decided
to check up on arjun and what he's doing
and i'm like okay he's like playing uh
he he he's playing like a madman and uh
it's time to show another game
and you guys will enjoy this one it
features an im so indian defense against
the very very strong uh grand master
rina jumbo babe uh we've covered uh
several of his games on the channel and
um if you guys remember last year in the
indefinite world cup he uh defeated
fabiano corona in that wonderful game
with the black pieces that we've covered
uh so
you know a very very strong player uh so
let's check it out it's quite the game
and uh
well
no no no more talking so here uh arjun
opens with d4 we have knight to f6 spawn
to c4 we have e6 and as advertised the
uh nimso indian defense is on the board
we have bishop to b4 and usually you
will see e3 here queen to c2 is very
popular those two are basically the most
popular replies to the names of indian
a3 also very popular with c9 to f3 but
one move that uh is also quite popular
but we just haven't seen it all that
much lately is the clock variation and
that is pawn to f3 preparing to grab the
full center with um
with e4 and interestingly arjun already
played this uh against the current world
number 17 in classical chess against
linear dominguez perez in the uh
olympiad that uh ended not so long ago
and he defeated um a lanier with uh with
this uh variation so let's see how uh
jumbo by prepared for this we have uh
upon the c5 challenging the center pawn
to d5 and now b5 this is the most uh
modern way of challenging this setup you
go after the the c4 pawn and then you
try to weaken the d5 pawn so pawn to e4
strengthening the the d5 pawn we have d6
and then now we have pawn to a3
challenging the bishop bishop back to a5
and now bishop to d3 uh we have castles
by jumabayev knight to e2 and now e
captures on d5 so this is all been
played before c capture is now pawn to
a6 defending the b5 pawn uh arjun
castles and now there is a game where h6
was played but here we have knight b to
d7 and it is now as of movie 11 that we
have a completely new game
and this is how renat is uh uh preparing
to challenge this uh setup by by arjun
so bishop back to c2 and now we have
rook to e8 uh and how do you how do you
uh
challenge the black setup here uh it
seems like you have this very nice
center okay and not all that much to
worry about but how do you actually push
for something uh well if you put this
position uh to an engine it will give
you all sorts of fancy ideas like h3
like knights the g3 elena's prophylactic
king to h1 so those are some of the
options that the engine really likes but
here arjun just plays g4 and this is a
very
very interesting decision as now you can
see that black's pieces aren't really
that ready to defend the king side the
bishop is on a5 the bishop blocked by
the knight the knight okay the knight is
coming to e5 but you are ready to
dislodge this knight with the g5 so
black will have to throw in a few moves
before he can start properly defending
and your bishop pair
is very very strong the queen has very
clear ways of entering the game the
knights can enter a game for example
this knight can come to g3 this knight
can be shifted to f4 uh maybe g3 to f5
so many ideas here so here we have h5 by
jumbo by preparing uh stopping g5 and
now knight the g3 we have knights to e5
also a very very good square for the
knight and knight c to e2 now preparing
to bring the knight over over to f4 we
have bishop to b6 now preparing some
nasty discoveries and a nice king to g2
we have pawn to c4 and now bishop to d2
now arjun is bringing this bishop over
to c3 to grab hold of this diagonal and
now knight after d7 shifting this knight
over to c5 and then of course the d3 if
this knight lands on d3 this will be a
monster knight so bishop to c3 and now
knight to c5 getting ready to play
knight to d3 and now we have h3 and now
uh it seems like uh
you really want to put that knight to d3
but once you put it you're not really
threatening anything and well it's uh
probably one of those that the threat is
stronger than the execution type of
positions where you is just best
uh wait with knight to d3 and improve
your position as much as possible but
it's hard to find the move that actually
improves the position for black so uh
here of course uh jamal is preparing
knight to d3 or maybe this knight to d3
the bishop is controlling this diagonal
so he throws in a nice queen to h4 and
it makes sense to bring the queen here
uh
so close to the white king good things
might happen uh but now comes queen to
d2 just nicely developing the queen
preparing to bring the other rook into
the game uh obviously not that way
probably d1 or e1 or depending on what
black plays we have bishop to d7 and
then now comes knight to d4 and now what
do you play here uh well best is to just
go back queen to d8 but it's hard to
hard to play such a move you you play
the names of india and you wanna counter
attack you want to you want to feel good
about your position and your knights are
placed beautifully here you have a
beautiful dark square bishop you have a
beautiful light square bishop your queen
is an h4 so this seems like a very odd
move to play but it is it is needed you
have to move the queen back because uh
well it just serves no purpose here and
uh after the move that was played in the
game it serves even less purpose here
aju mobile played g6 and it makes sense
it takes away the f5 square from both of
white knights but
it has one very very big flaw uh and
that is that it completely loses the
game but you have to find a exactly
precise order instead of moves in order
to pull this off so feel free to pause
the video and try to find the winning
idea for arjun
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
spectacular idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
ponte f4 yeah that's the good stuff uh
challenging this knight and uh just
saying uh uh
by playing g6 you've created a big big
problem because now the h6 pawn is a
weakness and it seems like you might
have some sacrifices here but you really
don't for example if you go knight
captures on g4 h captures and g4 you you
could capture it's a bishop captures and
g4 but
yeah
after rook to h1 there's really no way
to take advantage of this after rook h1
you're just much much worse there's no
good move you can make here uh so
instead after f4 we have knight e to d3
like we mentioned in that line only now
that the queen is here and that you've
played g6 it's just bad because the pawn
on h6 is undefended so here bishop
captures on d3 knight captures and now
knight to f3 kicking away the queen from
the active square queen back to d8 uh uh
from uh from from where where it came
from and yes uh
those those are just some of the
uh uh lines and squares that
white is controlling you can see that
white is all over the place here and now
of course pawn to f5 and that's the
exact set of moves that you had to see
and find uh in order uh to win this when
i asked you to find that uh
beautiful point f4 push so here uh g6 is
attacked h6 is attacked uh the the
bishop controls this diagonal so there's
uh really no way to defend this for
black g5 was played it's kind of the the
lesser of not two evils but of many
evils because there are too many threats
here so g5 uh this stops uh the threat
of just capturing an h6 but now uh pawn
to f6 you could also go for h for just
captures and rook h1 to grab hold of the
h file but f6 gets the job done and the
situation on the clock is 19 minutes for
arjun and renat has some 15 minutes on
the clock uh and here what do you play
uh there's always the question of knight
f4 check do you want to throw this in
but if you play it uh again king h2 uh
not not all that much to to play for for
example king h7 uh rook 8 to e1 and uh
black really does not have a move
there is really no useful move you can
make here like rook a7 uh just knight
captures and g5 and the white breaks
through completely now you know you've
even given him white a target for
example each capture through captures on
f4 h g captures queen captures on f4
and there's no defense they're just
queen g5 with queen h5 and that's it
there's uh uh
really no way uh that you can defend
this and if you play something like rook
to g then g5 is coming and yeah i mean
it is just a
a a really big mess of a position so
instead after f6 uh says all right i
can't really allow this uh to happen i'm
gonna have to give up the exchange he
plays knight to e5 and now just bishop
captures an e5 d captures an e5 and
still it seems like okay now you don't
really have a knife captures on g5
because the queen can capture on h6 but
that's exactly what arjun plays he plays
knight captures on g5
uh now the the rogue defends the f6 pawn
and there's really no good way to do
this for black if h captures on g5 just
queen captures and g5 of course black
gets check made it so here jumbo bob has
to figure out how to play this he plays
knight to f4 with check but of course
arjun immediately captures it and this
is the only winning move for white but
he calculated it many many moves ago so
he captures queen captures on f4 and now
bishop to d4 trying to uh snatch uh
snatch up that f6 pawn but just e5 and
now look at these pawns this is just
incredible even giving up the knight and
g5 but again it's you can never capture
this so bishop captures on b2 attacking
the rook but arjun says no problem just
knight captures on f7 and now what do
you play if king captures on f7 then
it's a matter of a very simple e6 check
for example bishop captures d captures
king captures and e6 now rook 8 to e1
check and you are either going to suffer
severe material loss and then get
checkmated if you go to the
default then let's say rook d1 will win
the queen or if you go to f7 then just
rookie 7 check and again king to g7 rook
to g7 check
there's nothing for you to do here king
f8 queen captures now all sorts of nasty
discoveries will
follow and uh that's just it so instead
of this uh after this um
wonderful uh knight captures an f7 move
we have queen to f8 as the queen was
attacked on the eight you have to play
something but now knight captures an h6
would check king to h7 and now even pawn
to g5 i mean look at this pushing those
pawns sacrificing an entire rook on a1
but
of course
everyone realizes that there is no
surviving this so bishop captures an a1
was played this is not a good move but
there is no good move uh in the position
so just bishop captures on a1 queen to
e4 with check we have king to h8 and now
queen to g6 now threatening knight to f7
check which will force black to give up
the queen so bishop e8 kind of the only
way to keep an eye on f7 but now just
pawn to f7
we have bishop to c6 you have to play
something you have to give back a little
bit of material
d captures now comes bishop captures on
e5 but now just knight h to f5 and he
was in this position on move 39 that
arena juba bayev resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
all of the squares here are covered
knight covers g7 bomb covers g8 there is
no defense queen the h5 check will force
black to give up the queen and then of
course black just gets checkmated so uh
it's pointless to continue uh resigns
and another spectacular victory for uh
arjun irigase uh who just keeps uh
piling up uh a win after win after win
and this is this is a classical uh event
uh i i forgot to
change the little b on the robot so
sorry about that i'm going to do it now
i don't want to finish the video
with a b on the row but you know it
might be weird so let's do that now all
right there's now a c there so it's
classical game in case yeah if if some
of you don't know yeah the the letter
and the robot actually uh states the the
format of the game uh i i'm just gonna
check something real quickly i wanna see
if the ratings got updated uh
oh he actually uh wow he actually jumps
the numbers
okay this is uh this is pretty crazy he
actually jumps to number 16 yeah because
uh today is the the first of the month
so uh he
jumped to number 16 from number 18 i'm
just gonna update it really quickly so
you guys can see it because this is uh i
mean this is just uh incredible stuff it
will take me like maybe 10 seconds so uh
stay tuned for that
uh wow this is uh
i did not see this coming like this uh i
knew he was 18 but 16 this is uh proof
okay so i don't want to trick you guys
or or you know misinform you guys there
we go
all right
uh so these are the the current uh world
top 20 in in classical chess let me just
enlarge this a little bit so you guys
can see it better
uh
wow i mean uh all right uh uh from the
top
it's pretty much the same because magnus
being i have not been playing uh any
classical games now uh we have neptune
third alireza unfortunate nakamura and
50 you guys know that but look at this
arjun irigase in number 16 in the world
uh okay if if if today wasn't the first
of the month he would have plus 50 uh
rating change uh but as today is the
first and the ratings got updated you
can see now that his official rating is
actually 27.35 so he's now in uh you
know
he was officially a 2700 player but 27
35
from the last time we checked that's
absolutely incredible
and uh number 16 in the world yeah he
overtakes uh laquan liam andreikin duda
and uh
and now uh to number 15 to alexander
grisha it will take 10 more points but
the way he is playing uh i don't know uh
we could we could see him at the at the
top ten i mean it would be if he
overtakes anand as the number one indian
player that will i mean that will
literally uh destroy the entire internet
uh so yeah uh that's the game thank you
guys for suggesting it like uh really a
tiny tiny mistake uh in the nimzo indian
here after this knight to d4 move just
uh you know this g6 move moves okay
queen here wasn't all that impressive
you could try something else but uh
yeah after this queen came here uh just
uh g6 was played and then uh the the h6
pawn became vulnerable and of course the
f4 move exploited it so i mean uh
beautifully played nimzo indian but the
the queen even though you feel the queen
belongs on h4 with all of your pieces
you know uh completely
uh uh sort of uh slicing and dicing
through through white's position the
queen just did not belong there and uh
arjun took advantage of that uh
perfectly
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it thank you for suggesting it
so quickly i mean way before it even
finished i i i i very much enjoy when
you guys suggest good games so quickly
uh i would like to thank uzi charlotte
frederick
uh petrol gavriel
gerald watts in the wood uh for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing um checking up on
your wonderful suggestions such as this
one and whatever else happens in the
chess world i have one more game plan
that i wanted to show uh but obviously
we will be checking up on arjun as he is
just uh he is just unstoppable these
days uh thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day and sorry it took me a bit longer to
to actually show you the uh the with the
world's top 20 uh
because i did prepare it before the
video but it just got updated during the
recording of the video so i you know i
checked and then now you know what i'm
talking about uh see you soon